[Music]
time is complicated I think more so than
space if you think about our mammalian
ancestors or mammalian cousins all
animals have a fairly good understanding
of space in the sense that they know
where a Predator is located behind a
tree or if my dog loses its treat it
knows to go behind the couch or beside
the couch or over the couch but time we
navigate space right we we take left
turns we right till we have a map of
space within our heads and we know that
if somebody goes around the corner where
we can go after them but time we don't
navigate time right time is this one-way
street and I think in part because of
that time is something that we never
evolved to manipulate to map out because
we have very little options time doesn't
have any branches or right turns or
exits or 180-degree wrap arounds so I
think the brain of of most mammals
didn't involve to manipulate to think
about time as much as space so I think
humans are unique in the sense that we
and perhaps we alone have this notion of
the past present and future being
fundamentally different from each other
and ability to map out time and any and
the same is true by the way in science
if you think about what's probably the
first field of modern science let's say
that's geometry right geometry as
formalized by Euclid over 2,000 years
ago is probably the first field of
modern science and why I think the
reason is is because the universe is a
simpler space place if we can ignore
time so geometry is basically the study
of a universe in which nothing changes
its space and objects that don't change
in time it took another took another two
thousand years for people great
scientists like a lay-oh a Newton
to fully incorporate time into
mathematics and physics and and to
further bring physics into its
Renaissance in which it fully embraced
time in its complexity biology as well
up until the 1800s biology was fairly
static until Darwin came along playing
the role of Galileo and said look
species change they're in motion they're
mutating and adapting I think
neuroscience is just reaching that stage
now in which it's fully coming to
embrace the time and it's full
complexity along with dynamics and look
at the brain as Time Machine of sorts so
the brain is indeed an illusion Factory
many of the things that we experience in
the world around us are an illusion in
one sense of that word so a common
example is color so color we perceive in
this vivid this vivid array of different
sensory experiences is something that in
many ways is an illusion because color
doesn't exist in the physical world what
exists in the physical world is
wavelength the wavelengths of visible
light of the electromagnetic spectrum
the brain if you will imposes a sensory
percepts which is subject to many
illusions the the intensity of green or
intensity of blue that we see often
doesn't exactly match the wavelengths
that we're seeing anyways so it's
reasonable to ask well maybe our sense
of time our sense of flow of time is an
illusion but I think there's an
important difference between those two
subjective experiences so our sense of
color correlates very tightly with
something in the external world with a
physical property which is visible light
and that's why it's adaptive so color
evolved our perception of color evolved
because it was adaptive it was a
evolutionarily adaptive to provide some
information about the external world the
color of a snake may tell us very
important information
it's poisonous or not now presumably our
sense of the flow of time should be
adaptive as well most of our subjective
experiences presumably have some
evolutionary advantage to them if if our
sense of the flow of time is an illusion
in the deepest sense meaning that it
reflects something that doesn't exist in
the physical world then it's a bit hard
to understand what would be the
evolutionary purpose of our sense of the
flow of time so I think there's there's
reasons and which to which physicists
and neuroscientists have to collaborate
more in to resolve these mysteries
should we look at the sense of the flow
of time our subjective sense with flow
of time which is very profound right
we're truly every human on the planet
has this unmistakable feeling of time
flowing and we have to decide if that
unmistakable feeling of time flowing by
is something that evolved because it
offered a selective advantage about
what's happening in the world and thus
its correlates correlates with a
property of the universe that really
exists or if in contrast it's an
illusion that doesn't correspond to any
property of the physical world and then
in that case physicists don't have to
explain the basis of evolution of
consciousness and I mean the illusion of
the of the nature of the flow of time
but neuroscientists have to work to
resolve that mystery on the other hand
if we accept that our sense of the flow
of time is a valid empirical observation
about the external world then physics
physics has to attempt to explain what
we are perceiving
[Music]